c'est oui toi Delphine quand même parce
que donc en 2021 2022 il y a eu 95 fait
donc 43 blessés légers 44 blessés graves
et 8 morts c'est énorme alors qu'il va
interdire la chasse le dimanche voilà et
après avec tous les gens qui n'osent pas
sortir en plus de peur de se prendre une
balle perdue donc oui il faut interdire
la chasse alimente quelle honte c'est
une manière sans le dire d'interdire la
chasse tout simplement
c'est à 50% les chasseurs ils ont moins
de 55 ans ils sont actifs le dimanche
s'il ne chasse pas ils vont chasser
camps par semaine
laissez-les chasser laissez-les nous
débarrasser des sangliers qui
maltraitent les récoltes mais c'est
incroyable Delphine c'est incroyable que
vous avez beau regarder vos notes c'est
débile ce que vous dites c'est fou
quand même dire que le président Macron
a divisé le prix du permis de chasse par
deux donc vraiment c'est il est il est
pour la chaîne
oui bien sûr
[Rires]
lâchez-moi du gibier
dans une heure
[Rires]
[Musique]
par semaine c'est raisonnable c'est pas
pour interdire la chasse complètement
parce qu'effectivement ça régule le
gibier et il faut conserver un minimum
mais pas le dimanche
échanger sa place avec moi
[Applaudissements]
vous vous êtes sympa mais voilà
68 % mais non à 31 % pour pouvoir se
promener tranquillement
régulation hein généralement c'est des
animaux d'élevage qui n'a même pas où
ils sont et ils sont lâchés comme ça
pour pouvoir les traiter si c'est
vraiment à part les sangliers les autres
c'est des animaux d'élevage sangliers
moi j'en ai vu la dernière fois
[Rires]
et je dis vraiment il y a des sangliers
qui vont attaqué je vous jure que c'est
vrai dans le sud il y en avait grave
j'étais tranquillement en train de
courir il y a 2 sangliers qui sont
arrivés
le bruit tu vois des des bails sur la
sur le bitume
au début je crois que c'était ma mère
parce que le bruit des talons tu vois
voilà ils ont comme dit qu'il y avait
quelqu'un qui courait avec des talons
derrière moi je dis c'est ma mère tu
vois un truc et bah non bien qu'elle
avait quatre jambes
ah oui si c'est ma mère et mon père
[Applaudissements]
je me suis dit mon père a dû partir
précipitamment il a mis des talons de ma
mère
tout simplement donc je me dis mon père
et ma mère me sont derrière moi
tout simplement j'avais oublié un truc
hyper important en fait non je me
retourne 208
et vous en français vous leur avez dit
en sanglier
[Rires]
et là il y en a un qui a voulu ça
racontait avec moi
là direct le sanglier sachez-le sur le
goudron il a il a du mal donc là direct
je balaye le sanglier les deux pattes
avant là il est comme
ce qui t'arrive là je suis mis une fleur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu te bagues avec lui
et on est venu hyper pote maintenant il
se dorme à la maison et tout ça